now on Saturday night British
heavyweight boxer Dillian white defeated
New Zealand's Joseph Parker putting him
firmly in the running for a world's
title fights and that could mean a
hugely anticipated rematch against
Anthony Joshua who Dillian actually
beats at amateur level he's a fan
favorite who's won a reputation for his
grit his power and his unpredictability
and he's with us now hopefully won't be
unpredictable this afternoon high up its
atmosphere in real life now just how
important was Saturday night to you it
was good it was a big fight you know
just be a guy I was really champion one
fire goal just lots of clothes from
decision and you know Joshua and vastly
experiences or any younger than me as
well
and what does it mean going forward for
you as far as the next stage of your
career is cuz they're looking at your
fighting as for Chester it means a lot
you know I keep fruit then people get
understand me and keep on running me
down
let's keep proving to them that I'm as
good as what I am items and I can be as
good as what I say I will be but down in
the 12th yeah yeah got not done like 30
seconds and the loss in the last run you
know it was do you think it was slipping
away from you no no I knew that I'm like
I can get through these little dark
patches I train hard and I've been
through so much in life though I knew he
just had never heard or to overcome okay
tell me how you felt when they said you
were the winner I felt good I feel good
because you know once again there's the
fact many people was gonna lose that
augmented lose but I knew I would it was
I knew I couldn't get the job done and
he's just gotta show us capable of doing
and you know I was the first person even
not Joseph Parker down and they thought
God Susanne people's better than me
stronger than me no Liam's ever knocked
him down and I'm I was managed to lose
nothing that they have nothing just sure
couldn't do so you know um are you ready
for that well title fight night yeah I'm
ready of you know I've come back from
defeat and injury and stuff on I'm gonna
eat what fact winning streak now and my
last four fighters have been top-ten
contenders including two former
champions I've just been too far away
champions back to back you know in fact
ik fashion as well so yes they knocked
him down twice today
yeah not known to us you know
before Joshua's not been able to do that
I did yeah exactly and the guy before
the fort it was a world champion it'll
never been stopped before undefeated and
I knocked him up so yeah you know I'll
experience and stuff is coming together
yeah I feel we're ready - we're ready to
push on now yeah can we talk about I
mean we'll talk about Anthony Joshua a
little bit but can I talk about your
character and what's made you who you
are I mean it was tough to start with
wasn't it
yeah yeah my old life so he's been tough
my whole life so he's a lot of darkness
and a lot of hard coal things that no no
child should go through you know well
it's maybe the press who I am and it's
made me a really tough resilient person
and it showed in the fight you know when
the chips was down I roll the dice you
know yeah I was at that of 13 of my mom
left me when I was 2 years old to come
to England I didn't see it till I was 13
so you know and it was hard I was
bouncing between family and I had a hard
life hard upbringing and stuff and then
eventually came here it wasn't an easy
it was difficult for me here being a
firing kid in a way but difficult I
spoke differently addressed differently
you know my mom and I kids so we
couldn't afford luxury or things all is
the way a hand-me-down and stuff like
that so you know was and people for
you're funny to take the America where
speak and stuff like that a school and
is that what made you tough you were
stabbed to you all sorts of things about
it's in a long long long long role you
know got shot twice being stubborn stuff
but you know it's just it's some other
things that come with growing up in a
city London you know I mean he just you
know yes you coulda turned a different
corner what made you take this one you
know what I was going down that road you
know one of the bad kids and stuff and
then I discover sports is their cover I
just cover combat sports and I started
training I go into the gym and then I
was always so tired from training always
in pain I was always going back to
training again it took up all must be
right yeah and it burned up makes energy
and stuff so you know that's always
encouraged kids and parents to try and
get day their kids involved in sports
because it does wonder so you know I
mean I find sports later fine school so
no
I'm 16 and I didn't really take it
seriously in my 20s you know which is
too late again if I added as fighting
sports when I was a kid or four would
have been an upgrade or have been now
you know pretty great now aren't you
Anthony Joshua on the car yeah it's a
fight we won he wants to fight I want to
fight but you know obviously he's got a
plan and I've got plans so I don't know
whether realistically I know he wants
the fact I don't think his team wants to
fight because they know dangerous am and
you know what risk of a possess you know
were fought twice already beaten once I
lost it once and both time before I hurt
him badly so they know what what racing
what danger are possessed but he's
really he's running of opponents and I'm
just right there now actually respect
his talent I respect him massively is a
great fire you know we spend ten rounds
in our career slugging it out it's a lot
of time and both time has been was you
know I mean it's a great good fire you
know me stuff is big guy and he's strong
and he's improving just like me but I
believe yeah when me and him mix I
believe this summer on the right
training and the right camber believer
being Miss Emma run it not him then who
and what's the can well you know this
dental white I was gonna fight Tyson
Fury our guy cam I know Joe's got a
version to the real tight was there
would be a retire but if not just for
idea I'd like to fight as inferior
Deontay Wilder how do i sum puri how
would you take him on Oh
taking one head of I'll take him on head
on that mean I mean meant a few is train
loads of spin that's the time boxing
Nichiren is coming up so I know a lot by
him my brand there is me you never
really know quite know what he's gonna
say out what he's gonna do
yeah I know but you know does boxing
that's what Singh I'm used to that you
know I mean that's just a way of trying
to get into people's head in channel and
so opponents you can't make those things
bother you know my off you can say what
he wants do what he wants under that the
fact we're gonna go to Warren and one
vegan guarantees I won't be backing down
mmm what do you do when you're not
boxing how do you relax spent over for
me play xbox walk my dog see my kids and
just just just I just like spending time
with my family I like see my family
messing about my brothers ever known
my sisters and stuff and just just being
a normal person you know the normal
stuff you know you go home I miss about
my mom Winer up and stuff like that you
know I never think about boxing my mom
doesn't like it but you know she knows
how much it's changed my life and what
is giving me
I know happy makes me so she supports
him because of that and I don't know Mom
normal wants to see their children
getting you know cause she billion see
me lose before you know she see me win
I've lost once you know then she was
there December and 2015 when I lost you
know she was devastated but it made her
pretty sure what do more I made it
become more supportive of my training
and trying to help me out more in and
around training so you know but she's
happy for me none because the way my
life is plan is even for me to be there
they're being prison by a certain age
and thank you thank you